[Musique]
pierre Geoffroy en somme c'est vous qui
dirigez cette équipe féminine qu'est-ce
qui vous a pris pour de former une
équipe féminine c'est à l'occasion d'une
organisation
une sorte de kermesse qui avait lieu
chaque année et on cherchait une petite
attraction alors on a prospecté un peu
parmi les sportifs de Reims finalement
ça suscité un engouement assez
intéressant alors on a fait le match on
a demandé une équipe alsacienne de venir
mais avez-vous eu des difficultés pour
recruter en somme féminine au contraire
on a eu beaucoup
plus les premiers jours on a fait une
sorte de sélection et puis après le
premier match qui était gagné justement
par les neuvices contre des joueuses qui
étaient plus chevronnés on était
encourage de continuer puis six mois ça
tourne
depuis combien de temps faites-vous de
football
l'annonce il y a eu ce journal
[Musique]
et comment vous y êtes venu
étant lorsque j'étais dans mon quartier
je voulais souvent avec les garçons j'ai
un peu garçon manqué quoi et puis j'ai
massé ce sport alors le jour où j'ai vu
l'annonce je suis allé aussitôt
avez-vous le trac quand vous pénétrez
sur le terrain
[Applaudissements]
mais aussi tout qu'on commence à jouer
c'est fini tranquille il est parti
vous vous sentez complètement libéré
êtes-vous marié depuis combien de temps
et votre mari parfois ne vous
adressent-ils pas de reproches préférées
peut-être vous voir rester à la maison
plutôt que d'aller sur un terrain au
parti en déplacement
je trouve que c'est normal qu'une femme
fasse du sport pourquoi pas le foot et
comme dans la famille tout le monde fait
du football par ma mère vous êtes marié
est-ce que vous n'avez pas quelques
réticences par exemple le dimanche matin
quand votre femme part en entraînement
est-ce que vous n'auriez pas préféré
qu'elle reste à s'occuper de votre
intérêt le fait le samedi
[Musique]